it is Star Wars week at Wired which
means it is Star Wars week on the
monitor and this week in your favorite
hive of scum and villainy ie right here
we've got Star Wars goodies galore we're
going to start with a comic book now
Dark Horse Comics has been publishing
Star Wars titles for a while now they've
licensed the universe and so they can
kind of do what they want with it but
beginning last month artist Carlos danda
and writer Brian Wood began a new
ongoing series just called Star Wars and
it takes place with the original trilogy
characters and the comic book begins
right after the original Star Wars movie
aka episode for a new hope and it
involves the rebellion in and Vader was
nice about this is it takes the the
character that you know from the trilogy
but instead of just doing ridiculous out
there stuff like the expanded universe
tends to do it kind of strikes a balance
oh yeah you've got Luke and Leia kind of
patrolling the Outer Rim territories
looking for a new world to base the the
rebellion on but you also have all the
dynamics and all the relationships that
already exist so you don't feel like
you're being led down the primrose path
with this you're not being asked to
invest in a bunch of new characters
there are new characters specifically
Leia puts together a sneak squadron of
rebel pilots doing something very very
for your eyes only that isn't a new
issue which actually comes out this week
episode 1 began in January in episode 2
Star Wars number two is out this week so
definitely pick that up so that's it for
comics we're actually going to talk
about tabletop games now in the world of
tabletop games there's a publisher
called fantasy flight and they have the
rights to the Star Wars brand so they've
been putting out a lot of great Star
Wars games recently from RPGs to card
games and a game came out last fall the
corset it's called x-wing miniatures it
is a miniature based kind of aerial dog
fighting game in which one player plays
the Empire the Imperial fighters and
another player plays the Rebel Alliance
and you you set up your ships and you
assign pilots to them if you have the
x-wing fighter say you can be Luke
Skywalker you could be Biggs or you
could be any number according to the
cards that are supplied with the set
then through a series of secret known
only to you moves planned in advance and
action sequences you engage the other
side in aerial combat you exchange blows
you can barrel roll there are hits their
critical hits there are evasion moves
it's actually way more tense and fun
than it sounds i'm not a huge miniatures
guy at least in the kind of swords and
sorcery world but i love this because it
kind of lets you play with spaceships
just like you did when you were seven
but their stakes are higher I don't know
why the stakes are higher the stakes are
higher because you're in your thirties
or I am but still it's a lot of fun
definitely recommend picking this up the
expansion packs including slave one Boba
Fett's ship and Millennium Falcon and a
couple of other smaller ships will be
coming out in the next month I believe
but the corset and the other expansions
are more than enough to get started
really a lot of fun that is x-wing
miniatures from Fantasy Flight Games
let's talk about pinball are you a
pinball wizard do you play by sense of
smell I don't I have my sight I have my
hearing I can speak I'm not Tommy but i
do love pinball and zen games who was
behind a lot of the better video game
pinball simulators is just putting out a
new Star Wars table pack includes three
tables one for boba fett one for Empire
Strikes Back and one for clone wars
which for my money is pretty much the
three most badass options you can have
when looking at Star Wars pinball what's
nice about these is the graphics are
fantastic either the pinball physics are
really really really good for the most
part what I like about it is with so
many pinball games and apps at least for
Xbox or iPad or what have you it's
sometimes tough to parse out what you
need to do to get X bonus or to activate
y thing but with the Star Wars games I
actually got a really instinctive feel
for pretty early on my favorite so far
is the Empire Strikes Back table which
has this great thing you can trigger a
stormtrooper levitating out of the table
and then shooting at your secondary
flippers with a with a photon blaster
which is really a lot of fun you try to
take them down anyway that is coming out
in I believe two weeks it is from zen
games it'll be out for geez console
downloadables it'll be out for android
tablet ipad believe pc
stuff a new trailers going up this week
and that is from zen games the star wars
pinball pack and that's it for the
monitor I mean we're going to be back
probably with some non Star Wars stuff
next week but until then may the force
be with you